This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Democrats were not the only ones to grin after the US presidential vote. Donald Trump's election has sent shockwaves through the world of pollsters and political analysts. Pundits on both the left and right had predicted Hillary Clinton would walk away with a race. Today, we're talking to one expert who got it right. There are several surprising things about him. For one thing, Alan Lickman is a historian, not a data scientist. For another, this wasn't a fluke. This is the ninth time in a row he's called the election correctly.
这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。在美国总统大选结束后，咧嘴笑的不仅仅是民主党人。唐纳德·特朗普的当选在民调专家和政治分析人士的世界里引发了轩然大波。左翼和右翼的政论家此前都曾预测希拉里·克林顿会轻松赢得这场竞选。今天，我们采访了一位预测正确的专家。关于他，有几个令人惊奇的地方。首先，艾伦·利特曼是一位历史学家，而不是数据科学家。其次，这并不是侥幸。这是他连续第九次准确预测出大选结果。
Finally, and this is the craziest part, Alan often calls the winner months and sometimes years before an election. He sometimes calls elections before he knows which candidates are running. Alan says his secret is sitting in plain sight, but most of us are too consumed with the drama of campaigns and candidates to see it. Alan Lichtman, welcome to Hidden Brain. Thank you so much. Alan, you're in the Middle East right now in a hotel room and cutter. I want to take you back more than a quarter century.
最后，也是最疯狂的部分，艾伦通常在大选前几个月，有时甚至是几年前就能预测出胜者。有时甚至在候选人名单尚未出炉时，他就已经做出了预测。艾伦说，他的秘诀就大白于天下、显而易见，但我们大多数人都被竞选和候选人的戏剧性所吞噬，以至于视而不见。艾伦·利特曼，欢迎来到“隐藏的大脑”。非常感谢。艾伦，你现在在中东卡塔尔的一个酒店房间里。我想带你回到四分之一个世纪以前。
You were at Caltech and you sat down to dinner next to another academic. You were an odd couple. You're a historian with an interest in American politics, and he was a geophysicist. Since our story begins at that dinner, can you tell me who you sat next to and what you talked about? Yes, this was in 1981, and I was sitting next to Valygia-Kyla's Borak, a geophysicist, the world's leading authority in earthquake prediction. And it was Kyla's Borak who suggested that we should collaborate. And of course, being a precient, force-sightful scholar, my answer was absolutely not. What does geophysics have to do with elections?
当时你在加州理工学院，晚餐时坐在另一位学者旁边。你们是一对奇怪的组合。你是一位对美国政治感兴趣的历史学家，而他是一位地球物理学家。既然我们的故事始于那顿晚宴，你能告诉我你坐在谁旁边，你们聊了什么吗？是的，那是在1981年，我坐在瓦利吉亚-凯拉斯·博拉克旁边，他是一位地球物理学家，也是世界领先的地震预测权威。正是凯拉斯·博拉克建议我们合作。当然，作为一个有远见、有先见之明的学者，我的回答是：绝对不行。地球物理学跟选举有什么关系？
And then I began to think about it a little bit. And everything we know about elections, we derive from geophysics anyway. Tremors of political change, volcanic elections, political earthquakes. So why not explicitly steal from geophysics? And what we did was we reinterpreted elections in geophysical terms. That is not as Republican versus Democrat, liberal versus conservative or caught versus Reagan. Remember this is 1981, but in earthquake terms, as stability, the party holding the White House keeps the White House and upheaval, the party holding the White House keeps the White House, and upheaval, the party holding the White House is turned out of office.
然后我开始思考这个问题。而且，我们对选举的所有了解，本来就是从地球物理学中衍生出来的。政治变革的震颤，火山般的选举，政治地震。所以，为什么不直接借鉴地球物理学呢？我们所做的，就是用地球物理学的术语来重新解释选举。也就是说，不是将其视为共和党对民主党、自由派对保守派，或是卡特对里根。记住，这是1981年。而是用地震的术语，将其视为稳定——执政党保住白宫，以及剧变——执政党被赶下台。
We'll talk in a moment about the specifics of the model you built, but to make things clear what you're saying is that you said, let's look at every presidential election as a referendum on the party currently holding the White House. That's exactly right. Our thesis was that elections are primarily judgments on the strength and performance of the party holding the White House. And all the twists and turns of the campaign, the ads, the speeches, the campaign tricks, the debates, count for little or nothing on election day.
我们等一下会讨论你建立的模型的具体细节，但为了说清楚你的观点，你是说，让我们把每一次总统大选都看作是对目前执政党的一次全民公投吗？完全正确。我们的论点是，选举主要体现了对执政党实力和表现的判断。而竞选中的所有曲折、广告、演讲、竞选伎俩和辩论，在选举日那天都微不足道，毫无作用。
But of course this was just a theory and to test our theory and to create a model we examined every American presidential election from the election of Lincoln in 1860 to the election of Reagan in 1980. And from that examination we came up with indeed the 13 keys to the White House. It's a very simple concept. The 13 keys are true false questions that can be answered prior to an upcoming election, sometimes years in advance if they fall into place. And an answer of true always favors the re-election of the party in power. An answer of false always predicts political upheaval the party in power will lose.
但当然这只是一种理论，为了检验我们的理论并建立一个模型，我们研究了从1860年林肯当选到1980年里根当选的每一次美国总统大选。通过这些研究，我们确实总结出了通往白宫的13把钥匙。这是一个非常简单的概念。这13把钥匙是可以用“对”或“错”来回答的问题，它们可以在即将到来的选举之前回答，如果条件成熟，有时甚至可以提前几年回答。回答“对”总是对执政党的连任有利；回答“错”则总是预示着政治剧变，即执政党将会失败。
And the decision rule is really simple. The party in power will lose if six or more of the thirteen keys are false. That was the model we came up with in 1981. So what you did, Alan, is you looked at every election starting in 1860 and you said, what are the factors that might have influenced this election? And you used that to come up with this model of 13 keys. What are these keys? Tell us a little bit about these keys and these 13 questions. Yes, these 13 questions primarily gauge the strength and performance of the party holding the White House. There are four political keys that have to do with midterm elections, contests for the White House party presidential nomination, whether
而且决策规则非常简单。如果有六把或更多的钥匙为“错”，执政党就会落败。这就是我们在1981年提出的模型。艾伦，你所做的是，你查看了从1860年开始的每一次选举，然后你问：有哪些因素可能影响了这次选举？你用它来构建了这个包含13把钥匙的模型。这些钥匙是什么？给我们讲讲这些钥匙和这13个问题吧。是的，这13个问题主要用于评估执政党的力量和表现。其中有四个政治层面的钥匙，与期中选举、白宫执政党的总统提名竞争有关，还涉及
the sitting president is running or not, third parties. Then there are a whole series of performance keys, short and long-term economy, scandal, social unrest, policy change, foreign policy successes, and failures. Only two keys relate to the candidates at all, and they're very high threshold keys. They ask whether the candidate of the White House party is one of those once in a generation charismatic candidates like a Ronald Reagan or John F. Kennedy. And
现任总统是否参选以及第三方政党。然后是一系列绩效层面的钥匙：短期和长期经济、丑闻、社会动荡、政策变化、外交政策的成功与失败。只有两把钥匙与候选人有关，而且它们的门槛非常高。它们询问白宫政党的候选人是否属于那种几十年一遇的具有个人魅力的候选人，比如罗纳德·里根或约翰·F·肯尼迪。还有
then they ask whether the challenging party candidate is charismatic. That is the only key, the 13th key, that is anything to do with the challengers. So this is fascinating because of course when we think about presidential elections and we think of the way the media cover presidential elections, we think it all comes down to the candidates and we pay enormous attention and you would say that is actually inordinate attention. That's right. I think the media covers elections as though they were horse races with candidates sprinting ahead
它们询问挑战党候选人是否具有个人魅力。这是唯一一把、即第13把与挑战者有关的钥匙。所以这很迷人，因为当然，当我们想到总统大选，当我们看到媒体报道总统大选的方式时，我们会认为这一切都归结于候选人，我们会投入巨大的关注——而你会说，那其实是不合比例的关注。没错。我认为媒体报道选举时，就像是在报道赛马，候选人根据竞选的曲折冲在前面
and falling behind according to the twists and turns of the campaigns with the pulsters keeping score. But the whole point is that's not how elections really work. The American people are fundamentally pragmatic and they are asking whether or not the White House Party merits for more years of office. And it's the record of the four years, the keys go term by term, that really counts not all of these events of the campaign that the media spends hundreds of millions of dollars covering each election. And as a result, almost all of the media coverage is not only irrelevant, it is largely misleading. It sends listeners and viewers and readers down into blind alleys.
或者落后，民调机构则在记分。但关键在于，这并不是选举真正运作的方式。美国人民从根本上是务实的，他们是在质问白宫执政党是否配得上再执政四年。真正重要的，是这四年的政绩（这些钥匙是按任期来划分的），而不是媒体在每次选举中花费数亿美元去报道的那些竞选活动中的种种事件。结果，几乎所有的媒体报道不仅无关紧要，而且在很大程度上具有误导性。它把听众、观众和读者引入了死胡同。
It's not quite right to say you are looking into a crystal ball. What you've really done is you've said looking back historically at dozens of elections, what are the different factors that played a role in each of these elections and you're saying history can be a guide when we look into the future. Absolutely, I'm not a psychic. I don't look at crystal balls. I don't have a pipeline to the Almighty. I'm an historian and my system is guided by a deep study of history that covers a very broad span of time all the way back
说你在看水晶球并不是很准确。你真正做的是回顾历史上的几十次选举，找出在每一次选举中发挥作用的不同因素，并且你认为当我们展望未来时，历史可以成为指引。完全正确，我不是灵媒。我不看水晶球。我和全能的上帝没有私密渠道。我是一名历史学家，我的系统以对历史的深入研究为指导，时间跨度非常广泛，一直追溯
to 1860 and thus is an extremely robust system that is it has survived enormous changes in our economy and our society our politics, in our technology. We go all the way back to the horse and buggy days of American politics. And that's the beauty of looking at history and using this pattern recognition methodology. When we come back, we're going to explore some of the extraordinary features of this model. It allows Alan to sometimes call elections long before candidates announce they are running. Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam.
到1860年，因此这是一个极其稳健的系统——也就是说，它经受住了我们的经济、社会、政治和技术的巨大变革。我们一直回溯到美国政治的马车时代。这就是审视历史和使用这种模式识别方法的魅力所在。当我们回来时，我们将探讨这个模型的一些非凡特征。它让艾伦有时能在候选人宣布参选的很久以前就预测出选举结果。请不要走开。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。
Alan, I believe that in 2010, you called the election for Barack Obama before his eventual opponent, Mitt Romney, had even declared his candidacy? That's correct. I was able to call the 2012 election, a very difficult election to call, with the polls almost even on the eve of the election in 2010. And the reason I could do that was I was programming the underlying structure of elections and Looking ahead to where the keys would likely fall I was able to ascertain that it was Extremely unlikely that six or more of the keys would fall against the White House party the party of Obama
艾伦，我相信在2010年，在巴拉克·奥巴马最终的对手米特·罗姆尼甚至还没宣布参选之前，你就预测奥巴马会赢得大选了？没错。我成功预测了2012年的大选。这是一场非常难以预测的选举，在2010年大选前夕，民调几乎不相上下。我之所以能做到这一点，是因为我是在对选举的底层结构进行编程，并且
And therefore Obama was going to win. I want to talk a little bit about the implications of this work a little later in this conversation, because I think it does raise really fascinating questions about how we come to know what we know and how we understand elections and how we should think about politics. But I want to stay a little bit with the model and your predictions. I understand that in 1991, you got a call from an obscure governor in Arkansas and Bill Clinton's people wanted to know if you thought that George H. W. Bush was vulnerable in the 92 election. That's exactly right. My first book on the keys, it's now in the sixth edition, came out in 1991. And at that time, George H. W. Bush had successfully
展望钥匙可能落脚的方向，我能够确定，六把或更多的钥匙指向反对奥巴马所在的白宫政党的可能性微乎其微。因此奥巴马将会获胜。我想在这次对话稍后探讨一下这项工作的意义，因为我认为这确实引发了一些非常迷人的问题，关于我们如何认识我们所知道的事物、我们如何理解选举以及我们应该如何看待政治。但我还是想多聊聊这个模型和你的预测。据我了解，1991年，你接到了阿肯色州一位默默无闻的州长的电话，比尔·克林顿的人想知道你是否认为老布什在92年大选中不堪一击。完全正确。我关于钥匙的第一本书出版于1991年（现在已经是第六版了）。当时，老George H. W. Bush刚刚成功
conducted the Gulf War. His approval rating hit the highest of any president in history, around 90%. And every big name Democrat was tumbling over every other big name Democrat to get out of the race. Mario Cuomo, Al Gore, Richard Gephardt, Jesse Jackson, none of them wanted any part of HW Bush. But I wrote in my book that based on my historical study, Bush is a codder, not a Reagan or one term president.
指挥了海湾战争。他的支持率达到了历史上面任何总统的最高点，约为90%左右。每一位大名鼎鼎的民主党人都争先恐后地想要退出竞选。马里奥·库默、阿尔·戈尔、理查德·格普哈特、杰克逊，他们谁都不想跟老布什扯上任何关系。但我在书里写道，基于我的历史研究，布什是个瑟瑟发抖的缩头乌龟，而不是里根，也不是那种能干两届的总统。
None of the big shots, of course, listen. But I get a call from a woman and she says, Professor Lickman, this is K-Gosk Hall and from Little Rock, Arkansas, Special Assistant to Governor Bill Clinton down here. And then she asks me, Lickman, are you serious that George Bush can be beaten in 1992? I said, yes, I am. And the rest is history. When did you call the 2016 election for Donald Trump? This was, of course, one of the most difficult and puzzling elections in all of American history to call because of the unprecedented nature of the Trump candidacy and other factors that were not entirely clear.
当然，没有哪个大人物听进去了。但我接到了一个女人的电话，她说：“利特曼教授，我是来自阿肯色州小石城的K·戈斯考尔，是那里的比尔·克林顿州长的特别助理。”接着她问我：“利特曼，你真的是认真的吗？乔治·布什在1992年会被击败？”我说：“是的，我是认真的。”剩下的就是历史了。你是什么时候预测唐纳德·特朗普赢得2016年大选的？这当然是美国历史上最困难、最令人困惑的选举之一，因为特朗普参选的前所未有性以及其他一些并非完全清晰的因素。
I made my call, I believe it was September 23rd in an interview with the Washington Post. My new, this was before the sex tape, before the allegations that about a dozen women came out with with regard to sexual harassment by Donald Trump before the Colme bomb shell letter about the Clinton emails. So this is an odd question to ask given that you call the election more than a month before it happened, but why were you so late this time? I was so late because we had in Donald Trump a history smashing candidate. And I was wondering if Donald Trump was so far outside the patterns of history that perhaps he could change the historical odds and he could
我做出预测的时间，我相信是在9月23日接受《华盛顿邮报》采访时。我当时的新——这甚至在色情录音门之前，在十几名女性指控唐纳德·特朗普性骚扰之前，在科米关于克林顿邮件的重磅炸弹信件之前。所以，考虑到你是在选举发生一个多月前做出预测的，问这个问题可能有点奇怪，但你为什么这次这么晚才做出预测？我这么晚才做是因为我们在唐纳德·特朗普身上看到了一位粉碎历史的候选人。我在想，唐纳德·特朗普是否如此超出了历史规律，以至于他可能会改变历史几率，并
destruct a pattern that had existed all the way back since 1860. We'd never seen a candidate who had no record of public service whatsoever, who had enriched himself at the expense of others, who had demeaned women, Muslims, African-American, the disabled, who had all kinds of scandals on his record. So, after you made this call and the access Hollywood tape is leaked where Donald Trump talks about how he groped women without their consent. Many Republicans denounced the candidate and some even said that he should drop out. Did you ever think at that point in October, early October of changing your call? No, I didn't. I was nervous about my
摧毁一个自1860年以来一直存在的模式。我们从未见过这样一位候选人：他没有任何公共服务记录，以牺牲他人为代价来中伤女性、穆斯林、非裔美国人、残疾人，他的履历上充满了各种丑闻。所以，在你做出这个预测之后，“访问好莱坞”的录音被泄露了，录音中唐纳德·特朗普谈到他在未经女性同意的情况下对她们动手动脚。许多共和党人谴责了这位候选人，甚至有人说他应该退选。在10月份的那时，即10月初，你有没有想过改变你的预测？不，我没有。我对我的
call and I had a lot of pressure with respect to my call, but I doubled down on my call even after all of that dirt on Donald Trump was revealed and before the Komi letter that kind of reopened the issue of Hillary Clinton's emails. In other words, if I'm to be true to my system, I am not going to let events of the campaign. However, dramatic, and regardless of what the pundits and the politicians might be saying, I'm not going to be influenced by that, because I think the polls are very badly misused, and I don't think the pundits actually understand how elections work, and therefore, a punditry is not a guide to understanding elections, predicting elections or explaining their implications.
预测感到紧张，并且就我的预测承受了很大的压力，但在所有关于唐纳德·特朗普的黑料被曝光之后，以及在科米那封重新引发希拉里·克林顿邮件问题的信件出来之前，我依然加倍坚定了我的预测。换句话说，如果我要对我的系统保持忠诚，我绝不会让竞选中的事件——无论它们多么富有戏剧性，也无论政论家和政治家们在说些什么——来影响我，因为我认为民调被严重滥用了，而且我认为政论家们根本不理解选举是如何运作的。因此，政论并不能指导我们理解选举、预测选举或解释其影响。
Now to be fair Alan, we have talked in the past multiple times after elections and you've told me in the past that the model correctly forecast a winner of the popular vote. In 2000 for example you call the election for Al Gore, even though George W. Bush won the electoral college in that disputed election. This time Hillary Clinton appears to have narrowly won the popular vote. So I guess it's fair to ask you, would it be more accurate to say that this is actually your first mistake in nine elections because Donald Trump didn't win the popular vote. That is a very fair question to ask. And what has happened that has changed my insights into the relationship between the popular
公平地说，艾伦，我们过去在选举后多次交谈过，你过去曾告诉我，该模型正确预测了普选的赢家。例如在2000年，你预测阿尔·戈尔赢得大选，尽管在那个有争议的选举中，小布什赢得了选举人团。这次，希拉里·克林顿似乎以微弱优势赢得了普选。所以我想问你这个问题很公平：说这是你在九次选举中犯下的第一个错误是否更准确，因为唐纳德·特朗普并没有赢得普选？这是一个非常公平的问题。而发生的事情——它改变了我对普选
vote and the electoral college vote is a fundamental change in our politics that is critically important not only for the keys but for understanding all of American politics. And it's something that really has not been broadly acknowledged. When I developed my system in 1981 and really up to 2000, the popular vote drove the electoral college vote. You had to go back all the way to 1888 to find a divergence between the popular vote and the electoral college vote. But in recent years,
与选举人团投票之间关系的看法——是我们政治中的一个根本性变化，这不仅对这些钥匙至关重要，对于理解整个美国政治也至关重要。而且这是一件至今尚未被广泛认可的事情。我在1981年开发我的系统时，实际上直到2000年，都是普选票驱动选举人团票。你必须一直追溯到1888年，才能找到普选票和选举人团票出现分歧的情况。但在近年来，
that relationship has been severed. And the reason is very simple. You have two huge uncompetitive democratic states, California and New York, where nobody campaigns for president. And those states roll up many millions of extra popular votes for the Democrats, even though those millions of votes don't count for anything in terms of the electoral college. And there is no comparable set of states that roll up those votes for the Republicans. The only example would be Texas, but Texas is no longer nearly for the Republicans as uncompetitive as New York and California is for the Democrats. So there has been a fundamental change in the dynamics of our elections, which is why
这种关系已经被切断了。原因非常简单。你有两个巨大的、缺乏竞争的民主党州——加利福尼亚州和纽约州，没有人会在那里为总统竞选拉票。而这两个州为民主党积累了数百万张多余的普选票，尽管这数百万张选票在选举人团方面没有任何意义。并没有哪个可比的州能为共和党积累这样大量的选票。唯一的例子可能是得克萨斯州，但得克萨斯州对共和党来说，远不像纽约和加利福尼亚对民主党那样缺乏竞争。因此，我们选举的动态已经发生了根本性的变化，这就是为什么
when I made my call, I did not draw the distinction between the popular vote in the electoral college, but simply said, this is going to be a change election, and the party holding the White House is going to lose. If you will, you might say, you know, I was wrong in 2000, although I don't think so, because there were some very special circumstances that gave those 537 votes in Florida and Bush, including the suppression and the discarding of many, many thousands of votes cast by African Americans. When we come back, we're going to talk more about the 2016 election and we'll talk about
当我做出预测时，我没有在普选和选举人团之间做出区分，而只是简单地说：这将是一场变革的选举，执政党将会失败。如果你愿意，你可能会说，你知道，我在2000年错了（虽然我不这么认为，因为当时有一些非常特殊的因素，把佛罗里达州的537票送给了布什，包括对数以千计的非裔美国人投下的选票的压制和作废）。当我们回来时，我们将更多地讨论2016年的选举，并讨论
some of the deeper implications of Alan's work. If someone can tell you who's going to win, months or years before an election, does it really make sense to follow the ups and downs of the election for 24 months before the big day? Stay with us. This is Hidden Brain, I'm Shankar Vedantam. Alan, I want to start by asking you about your call in September. I understand that you're not a personal fan of Donald Trump, and you know many people
艾伦这项工作更深层次的意义。如果有人能在选举前几个月或几年告诉你谁会赢，那么在投票日前24个月里关注选举的起起落落真的有意义吗？请不要走开。这里是“隐藏的大脑”，我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆。艾伦，我想先问问你关于你在9月份做出的预测。据我所知，你个人并不是唐纳德·特朗普的粉丝，而且你知道许多人
who were appalled at your call. And this was presumably difficult for you to make, difficult emotionally. I couldn't sleep at night when I made this call. I have to tell you. Personally, I think Donald Trump is a very, very dangerous leader who's brought out the worst elements in our society, the Ku Klux Klan, the neo-Nazis, the white supremacists. I've written about these issues.
对你的预测感到震惊。这想必对你来说很难做出，在情感上很艰难。我做这个预测时晚上都睡不着觉。我必须告诉你。就我个人而言，我认为唐纳德·特朗普是一个非常非常危险的领导人，他唤起了我们社会中最丑陋的元素——三K党、新纳粹分子、白人至上主义者。我曾撰文探讨过这些问题。
I wrote a book called FDR in the Jews. I'm a Jewish American myself and very sensitive, of course, to religious and racial prejudices. So I had many, many sleepless nights when I made this call. I teach at American University in Washington, DC, not exactly a hotbed of republicanism, and I had a lot of pressure from some very good friends of mine and some very smart scholars to change my call. And I had that pressure from the time I made the call, and certainly after I doubled down on that call right up to the election. So emotionally and spiritually, this was the most gut wrenching call I had to make but I felt I had to be true
我写过一本书叫《罗斯福与犹太人》。我自己也是一名美籍犹太人，因此对宗教和种族偏见自然非常敏感。所以自我做出这个预测以来，我度过了很多很多不眠之夜。我在华盛顿特区的美利坚大学教书，这里可算不上是共和党人的温床，我的一些非常好的朋友和一些非常聪明的学者给我施加了很大的压力，让我改变预测。从我做出预测的那一刻起，特别是当我在这项预测上加倍坚定、直到选举结束为止，我一直承受着这种压力。所以从情感和精神上讲，这是我不得不做出的最令人揪心的预测，但我感到我必须忠于
to my system. I had to be true to the verdict of history. Has it given you any satisfaction to be right? No it really hasn't given me a whole lot of satisfaction. It has in the sense that I think people may now start rethinking how they understand elections and understand how important governance is. That is governance, not campaigns that turn elections. And I have been preaching this for decades now and the politicians don't seem to get it. They think elections are one or lost during the campaign. I've argued they want in lost during the four years of the term of the
我的系统。我必须忠于历史的裁决。预测对了给你带来任何满足感吗？不，真的没有带给我多少满足感。它在某种程度上带来的满足是，我认为人们现在可能会开始重新思考他们如何理解选举，以及理解治理是多么重要。也就是说，是治理，而不是决定选举结果的竞选活动。几十年来我一直在宣扬这一点，而政客们似乎就是不明白。他们认为选举是在竞选期间赢或输的。而我一直主张，选举是在
administration and it's the governing that really counts. I have nothing against the pollsters. A lot of them are good friends of mine. They're very competent people. But I am saying polls are not predictors. Polls are misused and abused as predictors. I also think that polls lead to lazy and misleading journalism. You don't even have to get out of bed in the morning to write a story about the polls and it leads to this misconception that elections are horse races and it misses all the deeper tides that drive elections. It misses the implications of elections for governance in this country.
行政当局四年的任期内赢或输的，真正重要的是治理。我对民调专家没有任何意见。他们很多人都是我的好朋友。他们是非常称职的人。但我要说的是，民调不是预测器。民调作为预测器被误用和滥用了。我还认为，民调导致了懒惰和误导性的新闻业。你甚至不需要早起下床就能写出一篇关于民调的文章，这导致了一种误解，即选举是赛马，而它忽略了推动选举的所有更深层的潮流。它忽略了选举对这个国家治理的深远影响。
Look how the pundits tied themselves into pretzels. Right before the election they said, oh, based on the polls Donald Trump can't win. A day later they had to twist themselves around to explain why what they said couldn't happen actually did happen. And it was all after the fact and meaningless punditry. I have to say that as somebody who was not involved in covering this election, but somebody who was watching it very closely, there was something about watching the numbers that I saw on a lot of media websites and political websites that assigned a probability to Hillary Clinton's win that lent it an air of
看政论家们是如何把自己绕进死胡同的。就在选举前夕，他们说，哦，根据民调，唐纳德·特朗普不可能赢。一天后，他们不得不扭转说辞，来解释为什么他们说不可能发生的事情竟然真的发生了。这全都是事后诸葛亮，毫无意义的政论。我必须说，作为一个没有参与报道这次选举、但一直在密切关注它的人，在看到许多媒体网站和政治网站上对希拉里·克林顿获胜赋予概率的数字时，某种程度上给人一种
certitude. So even though people said in the caveats and the footnotes, look there's uncertainty, look we don't quite know what's going to happen and unpredictable things can happen. When you said Hillary Clinton has a 75% chance of winning the White House and 85% chance of winning the White House, you really had a sense of whiplash on election night because you said how could you switch around from saying you're 85% that Clinton's going to win to being 85% that Trump's going to win in a matter of 45 minutes. This is a classic example of what I call the fallacy of false precision. It looked like those of very precise and accurate numbers.
笃定的气氛。因此，尽管人们在警示和脚注中说：看，存在不确定性；看，我们并不完全知道会发生什么，不可预测的事情可能会发生。当你听到“希拉里·克林顿有75%的几率赢得白宫，有85%的几率赢得白宫”这样的说法时，你在选举之夜真的会有一种被狠狠当头一棒的感觉，因为你会说：怎么可能在短短45分钟内，就把“克林顿有85%几率获胜”转变成“特朗普有85%几率获胜”？这是我所谓的“假精确谬误”的典型例子。这些数字看起来非常精确和准确。
They are not. They are simply based upon the underlying polling data. And if the underlying polling data is flawed, then those numbers are not only meaningless, they are extremely misleading. They do not really tell you an accurate probability of winning because they're based on polls, which may or may not be right. And none of these analysts go beyond the polls to really probe whether or not the polls are correct. You and I talked in 2012 and you laid out this model for me and I remember doing stories about it.
它们其实不是。它们只是基于底层的民调数据。如果底层的民调数据是有缺陷的，那么这些数字不仅毫无意义，而且极具误导性。它们并没有真正告诉你一个准确的获胜概率，因为它们是基于民调的——而民调可能是对的，也可能是错的。没有一个分析师会超越民调去真正探究民调是否正确。你和我曾在2012年交谈过，你向我阐述了这个模型，我记得我做过关于它的报道。
Of course, it made no difference to the way people thought about elections in the next four years. I want to talk a little bit about that because I feel like there are many, many forces that really would not want to hear the message that you have. Certainly, you raise serious questions about the efficacy and value of political campaigns. You raise questions about political punditry. You raise questions about media coverage. You even raise, I think, disturbing questions for people who are voters, because
当然，这并没有对人们在接下来四年里对选举的看法产生任何影响。我想稍微谈谈这个，因为我觉得有许多许多力量真的不希望听到你带来的信息。当然，你对政治竞选的效用和价值提出了严肃的质疑。你对政治政论提出了质疑。你对媒体报道提出了质疑。我认为，你甚至对那些身为选民的人提出了令人不安的疑问，因为
I think people who are voters at some level enjoy the ups and downs of the campaign. They want to be gripped by the drama of who's up and who's down and who's who's suffering from a scandal and who's had a good day and who's won the new cycle and who's lost the new cycle. And what you're saying is deeply disparaging in some ways to all of these different constituencies because you're saying it doesn't matter. The keys are very deconstructive. And obviously they're very destructive to the polling industry
我认为身位选民的人在某种程度上享受竞选的起起落落。他们想要被谁领先、谁落后、谁正遭受丑闻困扰、谁度过了美好的一天、谁赢得了新闻周期、谁输掉了新闻周期的戏剧性所吸引。而你所说的，在某种程度上对所有这些不同的群体都极具贬低意味，因为你在说：这根本不重要。这些钥匙具有高度的解构性。而且显然，它们对民调行业
and to the media industry. Because the media makes money by covering the elections as an exciting horse race. By saying who's had a good day, who's had a bad day. They make money by covering the elections day by day. And the pollsters make money by keeping score in the horse race, telling us who's ahead and who is behind.
和媒体行业具有极大的破坏性。因为媒体通过把选举报道成一场激动人心的赛马赚取利润。通过报道谁度过了美好的一天，谁度过了糟糕的一天。他们通过日复一日地报道选举来赚钱。而民调专家则通过在赛马中记分、告诉我们谁领先谁落后，来赚取金钱。
And my model suggests all of that is misleading or worse. And if you covered it according to the deep structure, it would put a lot of pollsters out of business, and perhaps vastly diminish the revenue that flows into the media during an election campaign. This is the time, of course, when the media cash is in. There are also some very big lessons about campaigning from the keys that of course nobody has followed. The keys suggest that
而我的模型表明，所有这一切都是误导性的，甚至更糟。如果你按照深层结构来报道，就会让很多民调专家破产，并可能会大大减少在竞选期间流入媒体的广告收入。当然，这正是媒体大捞一笔的时候。从这些钥匙中，当然也存在一些关于竞选的重大教训，但没有人遵循这些教训。这些钥匙表明，
conventional campaigning takes us in the wrong direction. That all of these negative ads, all of these attacks on one another are the wrong way to campaign. That the right way to campaign based on the keys is to build a mandate for governing over the next four years. That might not be as exciting as email or sex scandals, but that's the way you establish a basis for governing. That's for the good of the country, but campaigners and the media don't follow that because it doesn't have the same excitement and drama of negative campaigning and day-to-day
传统的竞选活动把我们带向了错误的方向。所有这些负面广告、所有这些对彼此的攻击，都是错误的竞选方式。基于这些钥匙，正确的竞选方式是为未来四年的治理建立一个授权。这可能不像邮件或性丑闻那样激动人心，但这才是你为治理奠定基础的方式。这对国家是有好处的，但竞选人和媒体并不遵循这一点，因为它不具备负面竞选和日复一日的赛马报道那样的兴奋感和戏剧性。
horse race coverage. Alan, I'm going to ask you to make a prediction, and I want to make a prediction as well. There's much of what you say that I find persuasive, but I'm going to predict that in two years time, we're going to start hearing about the ups and downs of the 2020 campaign, and the next election is going to be just as frenetic and just as poll driven and just as down to the wire excitement coverage as we've had in 2016. What's your prediction? Well, you just depressed me immensely, but I have to say, for over 30 years,
艾伦，我要请你做一个预测，我也想做一个预测。你所说的话中有很多我都觉得很有说服力，但我预测，两年后，我们将开始听到关于2020年竞选的起起落落的议论，下一次选举将会像2016年一样，充满狂热、被民调驱动、并且充满逼近最后一刻的兴奋感报道。你的预测是什么？好吧，你刚刚把我狠狠地打击了，但我必须说，30多年来，
I have been arguing against exactly what you mentioned. So far, I haven't made a dent in the way campaigns are covered or in the way candidates campaign. But I have never had the kind of attention that I've had after this kind of contrary to everybody else's prediction of a Trump win. And one that certainly does not reflect
我一直在反驳你刚才提到的这种现象。到目前为止，我对竞选报道的方式或候选人竞选的方式还没有产生任何实质影响。但我从来没有获得过像这次预测特朗普获胜之后所得到的这种关注——这是一个与所有其他人的预测都相反的预测。
my own political views. It was hardly an endorsement, it was a prediction. So maybe perhaps the attention I've gotten from this prediction will make people rethink even a little bit the way they look at elections, the way they look at our politics, and maybe, maybe bring together politics, governing, and history the way the keys do. Adam Lichtman, I want to thank you for talking with me today. Shankar was a great conversation.
这绝对不反映我自己的政治观点。这绝不是背书，这是一个预测。所以也许，我从这个预测中获得的关注，会让人们哪怕稍微重新思考一下他们看待选举的方式、他们看待政治的方式，并且也许——也许能像那些钥匙所做的那样，把政治、治理和历史结合起来。艾伦·利特曼，我想谢谢你今天与我交谈。尚卡尔，这是一次很棒的对话。
The Hidden Brain podcast is produced by Tara Boyle, Jenny Schmidt, Maggie Penman and Renee Clarre. For more Hidden Brain, you can follow us on Facebook and Twitter and listen for my stories on your local public radio station. If you like this episode, please do a couple of things. Make sure you are subscribed to our podcast so you get new episodes. And please tell one friend who doesn't know about us to listen to our show. Our unsung hero this week is Tanya Blue.
“隐藏的大脑”播客由塔拉·博伊尔、珍妮·施密特、玛吉·彭曼和蕾妮·克拉尔制作。想收听更多“隐藏的大脑”，你可以在Facebook和Twitter上关注我们，并收听你在当地公共广播电台上的我的故事。如果你喜欢这一集，请做两件事。确保你订阅了我们的播客，以便获取新集。并请告诉一位还不知道我们节目的朋友来收听我们的节目。我们本周的无名英雄是坦尼娅·布鲁。
Tanya works in NPR's development department and she has played a vital role in getting this project launched. She's also been a voice of Y's council and someone who has always looked out for us. Thank you, Tanya. I'm Shankar Vedantam, and this is NPR. you There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
坦尼娅在NPR的发展部门工作，她在推动这个项目的启动方面发挥了至关重要的作用。她也是理智的顾问和一直关照我们的人。谢谢你，坦尼娅。我是尚卡尔·韦丹塔姆，这是NPR。本集目前尚无评论。点击转录文本中的任何句子即可发表评论。